I'm so disappointed because
I just don't think I can do this anymore
[Music]
but I feel like it's gonna be a journey
and at the end of the road it's gonna be
great
I'm 35 years old and I was just
diagnosed with ADHD so come with me on
the start of my latest health Journey
because I think this one is gonna change
my life
[Music]
foreign
welcome to my Vlog if you caught my
video a few weeks ago I was recently
diagnosed with ADHD and it finally feels
like all of the tiny little pieces of my
mental health Journey are finally coming
together but before I get into the Vlog
definitely check out my disclaimer this
is not medical advice this is just my
journey if you suspect that you have
ADHD please speak to your health care
provider and if you do have ADHD also
speak to your health care provider
everyone's experience especially around
medication is going to be unique also a
heads up that I will be talking about
drug dependency and stimulants so please
skip this video If that is triggering to
you okay hold up for a second I want to
tell you about today's sponsor element
so I'm really honored to be working with
element because this is a product that I
was using years ago when I was on my
breastfeeding Saga and it really really
helped me recover I ended up getting
back into it when I spent a few months
down south this year because because I
just have a really bad tendency to get
heat stroke or get super dehydrated in
the Sun so this really saved me a lot of
my colleagues who work in sports and
nutrition also swear by elements
specifically because it has a
science-backed electrolyte ratio of a
thousand milligram sodium 200 milligrams
potassium and 60 milligrams magnesium
and it has no colors sugar or fillers
I've also found the having my
electrolytes in the morning has also had
a huge impact on my sleep so even on
days that I'm not sweating a lot I'll
usually still have at least half a
packet I love all things spicy so the
mango chili is my current Obsession but
they have nine different flavors
including their new grapefruit which I
also really love right now element is
offering my viewers a free sample pack
with any order so that is eight single
serving packets for free with any
element order and this is a really great
way to try all eight flavors or to share
element with a salty friend so you can
get yours at drinkelement.com Abby sharp
and this deal is only available through
my link so you got to go to
d-r-i-n-klmnt.com slash ABI Sharp
hmm
so good all right kids I'll catch you on
the other side I said I wasn't gonna
medicate
like I told myself that getting this
diagnosis was just going to be like a
good to know like a validation basically
of everything that I've gone through all
of my life up till now and it has been
it's been so validating but I just came
to this realization of how beneficial
like how life-changing medicating for my
anxiety and my insomnia has been like my
biggest regret at this point in life is
that I didn't do it earlier and so I
guess I'm just curious what medicating
for ADHD will do for my life what doors
could this open for me so I'm going to
take the plunge
wish me luck all right it is day two on
Vyvanse uh I woke up with like a little
bit of a head cold which is like why it
is summer why am I getting sick uh but
let me tell you where I'm at so
basically I can see why people love this
stuff because I am in the best mood
despite feeling kind of I don't think
I've ever felt this level of mental
calmness and energy at the same time
it's a very strange juxtaposition but I
love it that said I am tragically
constipated and normally when I'm
constipated it is like the end of the
world I am so cranky I'm so irritable
I'm so triggered because of my history
with sibo and you know the fact that I
have come so far on my IBS and just like
healing my gut and supporting my gut and
I'm in a really good place normally so
when I do feel like I'm off my usual
bathroom routine I like I am an anxious
wreck but what today
somehow I feel just like more nonchalant
about it like I'm
like I'm at peace with the fact that I
can't poop
yeah I might feel a lot crankier later
when I kind of come down from this high
and also when I get a little bit more
bloated and uncomfortable but for now
I'm going to channel this energy and
take myself for a little waxy
all right it is day five of me taking
Vyvanse and I've got a lot of thoughts
and a lot of updates so first of all I
really love how it makes me feel some of
the times in some ways like when I first
wake up in the morning I have so much
energy I'm in such a good mood like I I
love my kids I love my husband the whole
day is going to be an amazing day like I
don't know I'm in I'm vibing with myself
is you doing a good job you're
doing a good job and I I've really
haven't felt like that in a really long
time slash ever
um normally I move through the morning
in such a chaotic frantic way like I'll
make the kids breakfast and I just can't
bring myself to like put it away it just
feels like there's just too much going
on I just remember doing a vlog one time
where somebody made a comment like it's
so messy you're so chaotic everything's
a mess and I'm like yeah it is messy
like my whole the way I think is messy
wow this is a weird look but I did I let
my hair air dry today which I never do
so that was mistake number one like I
normally feel like a little bit of a
tornado just moving through the day and
now I feel like I can actually make the
kids breakfast and put things away and
tidy up and manage them and interact
with them and be in a good mood and not
be cranky
Etc also I was reading my son a book on
the Titanic this morning which is
something this is a book that I have
read maybe three or four times in the
past two weeks so this is not like a new
book for me and for the first time I
found myself as I'm reading this being
like oh I didn't know that that's what
happened oh that's you know who took the
call oh that's how it first smashed into
the iceberg Etc like I was actually
learning what happened for the first
time even though I had read the story a
million times before so it's not that I
just like had short-term memory loss and
I blanked out it was that all the times
before that I read this book I was just
seeing the words and regurgitating them
but not actually obtaining any knowledge
this was the first time that I actually
obtained Knowledge from what I've read
how have I managed to be so successful
how was I such a great student like I
graduated literally top of the class of
all time like I just realized how much
mental energy I've spent over the past
35 years just to obtain enough knowledge
in order for me to have the success that
I've had and it has like shook me to my
core that had I come to this realization
or being diagnosed 10 to 20 years ago
how much further could I have gone
because I feel like I've done a lot in
35 years and I'm really smart but had I
been able to concentrate better when I
was in school when I was an internship
when I was learning to become a
dietitian I would have been able to
become smart without it almost
killing me because that is what school
and education did to me it drove me into
the ground so that's good another
unusual perk that I'm experiencing is
that I'm not remembering my dreams which
might seem like not a good thing for you
guys who like dreaming but my dreams are
so intense and Vivid and often really
terrifying who are you
um and I dream many of them that I often
say to my therapist that I feel like I
live a whole other life at night and if
you can imagine when you're supposed to
be resting at night living a whole other
life with people who may or may not be
in your real life it is exhausting and I
wake up every morning very exhausted and
not rested even though I may sleep eight
hours and the past few days I've woken
up and I've not remembered my dreams or
I've remembered it so vaguely that it is
not significant it's not weighing on me
it's I'm not thinking about it all day
long I think about my dreams normally
until I go to bed the next that that
night again and it starts all over again
so it's like I I work really hard in the
day and then I work really hard at night
and I feel like maybe my brain is
relaxing finally enough that I can rest
when it's time to go to bed so that is
that is life-changing in itself so yeah
that was the good but there's bad as
well there are things that I do not like
about this so far at least uh one the
constipation I was not I was not warned
about the constipation the other thing
that I feel a little uneasy about is
just my fear of dependence because you
know I was taking between 20 and 30
milligrams and yesterday I took just 10
milligrams because it was a day off and
my goal here was to be able to take the
medication during the weekdays when I
need to feel concentrated and get my
work done and then the weekends not take
it because that's what a lot of my
friends and colleagues who take ADHD
medications are able to do but I even
took 10 milligrams yesterday to try to
hopefully like get my digestion back on
track and I have to be honest I felt
fully depressed I felt like I was
walking through mud all day super
sluggish just not like myself so that to
me is really concerning I don't like the
way that feels I would rather feel no
high at all than to feel like in a dark
dark place when I don't take the
medication and this has only been five
days so I am legitimately concerned
about that but I'm gonna go eat my kiwis
now and I will check back in with you
guys later
okay so I spoke to my dietitian Caitlin
self she's amazing I'll leave her
contact below
um about my symptoms and one of the
interesting things that she said is that
in her experience one of the main
reasons for constipation with the folks
that she sees on Vyvanse is because
they're not eating enough because a lot
of ADHD medications these stimulants
they can suppress appetite and when
we're not eating enough it can slow down
our gut motility and I already know this
I've talked about this ad nauseam in
relation to why we see more functional
gut disorders when it comes to eating
disorders interestingly I haven't
noticed any impact on my appetite yet
though obviously I'm taking a very low
dose still so that might happen
um so I don't think that I'm under
eating and if anything I probably am
eating more than normal because I'm kind
of like throwing all my you know my
anti-constipation uh Foods at me so I'm
bulking up on a lot of high fiber foods
lots of nuts and avocados and lots of
fruit and whole grains and things like
that so I'm kind of thinking more about
adding more foods to my diet right now
than I am about taking them away even if
I'm not particularly hungry so I don't
think that's my issue but if you do find
that you've lost your appetite as a
result of taking a stimulant which is
very common here are some really quick
tips in terms of making sure that you're
meeting your nutrient needs number one
set a meal and snack schedule so this is
really important for kids but also very
important for adults so if that means
you need to put an alarm on to remind
yourself to eat even though you may not
have those hunger cues really super
important because as you get used to the
schedule your body will adapt and it'll
start to anticipate that fuel coming and
you'll start to get those hunger cues
back number two small frequent meals
around every three or four hours and
this is also really important for nausea
which is something that I feel I'm
getting like a little bit nausea but
it's not extreme or debilitating in any
way but for some people it definitely
can be so small frequent meals really
key as opposed to having like
intermittent fasting and then having a
big meal not recommended when you've got
low appetite and then finally we want to
focus on low volume high calorie meals
and snacks so you know things like oh
Poppy
I gotta go get her one sec
so yeah focus on those higher calorie
foods that are lower in volume so as
opposed to having like a really big low
calorie salad I want you to think about
peanut butter toast and you know protein
smoothies with nut butter in there and
trail mix and things like that that are
going to be able to eat very easily
without a lot of volume also a lot of
people find that their appetite is a lot
better in the evening as opposed to the
morning oh she we've discovered that she
gets freaked out when I'm like talking
to a camera because she's like who is
she talking who is she talking to she's
like she thinks I'm yelling at someone
having an imaginary conversation so
that's why she's always barking at me
right it's not because you want to to
eat though that's also a possibility but
anyways
um yeah a lot of people find that their
app tastes better in the evening so
definitely try to capitalize on that by
having a large dinner and a bedtime
snack get that bedtime snack in there um
I want to show you what I'm making so
let's see so I'm going to make myself a
little poo promoting
um uh snack here a little smoothie this
is something that Caitlyn recommended
and I was like this is a great little
combination so let me show you what I'm
going to do see when I go on my team
here things are not always so well
produced I got celery juice you guys
know how I feel about that and you know
how I always say that if celery juice
detoxes you it's because it's got so
many fodmaps in it that it helps to get
things moving
out of me like lava we're gonna do some
celery juice never something that I
would want to consume on its own so kiwi
we know has lots of research to suggest
that it can help with constipation and
bloating this is a massive kiwi so I'm
only going to use one but usually the
clinical doses too but this is this is a
Honker I've got some pear here that I
cut up yesterday a little honk of
cucumber this is the ground so it
doesn't like get as gelatinous I'm not
even going to peel it I'm just gonna
throw it in like that all right let's
see how this goes
[Applause]
okay guys you got the picture I blended
it up this is what it looks like it's
not pretty but let's have a taste
mmm
that is good I never think to put kiwi
in a smoothie but it works it's so like
Tangy and zingy it really works with the
ginger I definitely can get on board
with this and I like that it's not
gloopy like chia pudding all right I'm
gonna go down this and hope that it gets
things moving and since we're on the
topic of food I figured I would hop in
here really quickly to briefly talk
about foods to focus on and what to
avoid when it comes to ADHD so this is
definitely an area of research that's
still evolving so take some of this with
a grain of salt but it is worth
experimenting to see what works best for
you so the big ones we typically hear
about are reducing artificial food dyes
and excess sugar I'm generally pretty
cautious about food dyes in our house
since I noticed when I was a little girl
that I was kind of sensitive to them
they actually give me a bit of a rash so
I've just personally always avoided
buying things with food dyes outside of
like special occasions like birthday
cakes and things like that
um otherwise I don't usually serve them
to myself or to my kids but there is
some evidence that food dyes can
exacerbate symptoms in folks with ADHD
there's also some evidence to support
reducing some preservatives like sodium
benzoate which is usually found in
things like soda store-bought sauces
condiments things like that plus
nitrates which you typically find in
things like bacon and deli meats but
honestly I don't think we need to obsess
over every single packaged food that we
eat I think if we just focus on limiting
highly processed foods which I generally
do we can typically reduce the risk also
on the topic of Highly processed Meats
one of you did find that a diet high in
saturated fat may also increase the risk
of ADHD so mainly that means animal fats
like high fat Dairy high fat meat Etc
personally I don't really eat a lot of
red meat and the dairy that I choose is
fermented dairy like yogurt cottage
cheese and that's only like five percent
fat so those are things that are not
typically a concern for me and then
there's sugar so whether or not sugar
causes hyperactivity is like super
controversial but one review found that
it may increase the risk in kids with
ADHD even though the evidence is weak at
best interestingly one of the common
symptoms of ADHD is like sugar Cravings
or sugar addiction basically because we
need a bigger dopamine hit to feel the
effect of those pleasurable things I
actually used to describe myself as
having a really really severe Sweet
Tooth but now I think that intuitive
eating and food Freedom has really
suppressed that or maybe it's just like
age but yeah I don't personally feel
like I want to eat all the sweets
anymore you'll also see that there's a
lot of talk online about avoiding
artificial sweeteners if you have ADHD
though there really isn't any good
evidence to support that at this time I
would say that if you are sensitive to
them I feel like it's an easy thing to
remove personally I already avoid things
like Splenda and aspartame and other
artificial sweeteners mainly because
they're not great on my gut and I tend
to get headaches from them and I just
don't like the flavor of them so I may
personally be sensitive but I'm already
cognizant of that and have basically
removed them from my diet so those are
the things that you'll read most often
about reducing the diet when it comes to
a protective effect we know that a diet
rich in fruits and vegetables seems to
be the best bet surprise surprise so
like this is not rocket science folks it
doesn't take rocket appliances eat
fruits and vegetables avoid highly
processed foods and additives focus on
higher fiber carbs over the really
higher sugar ones and choose more
unsaturated fats over saturated I'm
doing all of those things and have been
for years so yeah nothing really to see
here folks another thing we can talk
about though is the commonly recommended
supplements for ADHD so this is my
supplement bin I don't take all of these
or all at once but I do have them all in
hand for different times of my life so
the first one that's often recommended
for ADHD is iron because some research
does show that iron supplementations can
improve ADHD symptoms though obviously
you'd want to do blood work first to
determine if this would be helpful for
you my iron levels have always been
really good so I don't need iron at this
time at least
zinc is another one and this is one that
I do personally take every day and this
is because it can help regulate the
normal Pathways of chemical Messengers
in the brain so that's another one to
maybe look for in your blood work next
is Omega-3s which I already take we have
evidence that supplementing with
Omega-3s may help to improve symptoms
since Omega-3s help to reduce oxidative
stress and improves that chemical
messenger Transmission in the brain also
vitamin D and this is one that I
recommend most people take because half
of us are already vitamin D deficient
and we specifically have evidence that
can help with ADHD symptoms and then
magnesium which oh here she is this is
one of my favorite supplements that I
take personally apparently people who
have ADHD tend to have lower magnesium
in the body than those who don't have
ADHD so supplementation can help ADHD
symptoms and it can also help with
insomnia and anxiety which tend to
coexist in folks with 80 HD so I'm going
to finish chopping up some fruit for
lunch and then I'm going to fill in my
pill packs for the week and I'll catch
up with you guys soon
I'm so disappointed because
I just don't think I can do this anymore
like I'm on such a low dose and yet the
crash by the end of the day is so
unbearable
like last night I was running a bath for
my kids and I was trying to say the word
cold but instead I said black
down and Moon
like I can't even form a sentence I was
talking to my doctor and I couldn't even
form a sentence so like my brain is
obviously not working very well when I
come down off this thing and like my gut
is telling me that this is not good for
me that this is like a slippery slope
for me that this might be doing more
harm than good but my rational mind is
saying you know you got to try this out
you gotta see it through this is a
process every you know psych drug is
always a process and it's never a fun
process right these Journeys
suck
and they especially suck and feel
especially hard at the end of the day
when I'm like
at a low
I don't like this feeling
I don't like feeling
depressed which is kind of where I am
right now but I'm just trying to take
this one day at a time
okay I have to end this video on a
positive note I cannot believe you guys
hang in here but I have a plan and I
feel really good about it so basically I
did a quick little Switcheroo to buy
Fenton instead of the Vyvanse so it's a
different class of ADHD medication
um and I definitely found it was a lot
better in the sense that I wasn't
getting as extreme highs and lows
um and I also didn't find that it was
causing me to be as constipated so that
was a huge plus that said you know I
still didn't feel 100 like myself and I
do think that that just is a matter of
you know me kind of recalibrating and
taking time but I basically only took
two doses of it and my husband just let
me know that he's going on a little trip
for four days so I'm gonna be alone with
the kids for a few nights and honestly I
just don't feel comfortable with that
knowing doing that this drug is still
making me feel a little bit dizzy I'm
not feeling like 100 100 myself I'm
sleeping better which means I may or may
not wake up if the kids are screaming
for me or if they need me I'm not sure
I'm able to drive them somewhere in the
middle of the night if we have an
emergency
Etc so for that reason I just decided
okay I'm gonna take a pause on this
um and unfortunately because my husband
as soon as he gets home we're going
straight to the UK which is also not a
great time to start a new medication
from scratch considering all the
different variables I thought all right
we know that this is possibly going to
change my life but I have to wait I have
to wait for it to change my life because
I've got too many other variables going
on that is not my normal routine so I'm
gonna pick this whole journey up again
when I get back from all of my holidays
in the fall and I think that that's just
a better move that way I can kind of
utilize its benefits When I need the
most as opposed to when I'm on holidays
just chilling out with my kids so
I'm really good about this plan I know
I've had a little taste I like the taste
even though there's some spicy bits in
there but I feel like it's gonna be a
journey and at the end of the road it's
gonna be great signing off
well kids another stage another struggle
but I hope you guys enjoyed this Vlog I
will definitely keep you updated on the
next phase of my journey if you like
this video be sure to give it the thumbs
up if you have specific questions about
my journey or about ADHD in general
definitely leave me a comment below and
I will try to get to them in an upcoming
video subscribe to this Channel and I'll
see you next time on Abby's kitchen bye
[Music]